Fox News contributed Newt Gingrich
you have been steadfast in terms of
predicting that this this environment
that Republicans are now running in the
fact that Democrats have nothing
positive to run on that they're now back
to the old scariff seniors uh
Republicans are going to take away your
Social Security and Medicare uh to me
that's a sign of desperation uh let's
walk through what you see what you
predict what's going to happen on
Tuesday night
well I think at a general level we're
going to be somewhere between
plus three and plus five in the Senate
the one which I think is hanging in the
balance is a terrific candidate Tiffany
Smiley in Washington state well
Washington State's a very tough state
for us but I think we're going to win
all the Republican seats which will
include oz in Pennsylvania JD Vance and
it will include you know people like
Marco Rubio handily and we're going to
keep the seed in North Carolina and then
Wisconsin with Ron Johnson then I think
we're going to pick up balduck for
almost certainly is going to win in New
Hampshire as people go out and fill up
their heating oil tanks for the winter
the price shock is enormous and Hassan
is a very very weak Senator I think
we're going to pick up
the seed in Nevada where we have Adam
laxalt in Georgia I actually look I'm an
optimist I think Herschel is probably
going to win Herschel Walker he's going
to win without a runoff I think that
Brian Kemp has done such a great job put
together such a powerful team that he's
going to beat Stacy by a big margin and
in that process I think he's going to
carry Herschel above 50 percent and then
I think frankly Blake Masters is going
to win in Arizona where you have and
Kelly somebody who pretends to be a
moderate but in fact has consistently
favored more IRS agents over more border
patrol and people of Arizona know it so
I think it's going to be a great night
on the house side will be somewhere
between plus 20 and plus 50. I
personally think it'll be about 44 and
Kevin McCarthy is the next speaker
wow that is a very bold uh prediction
when you think of all these races a lot
of them are either dead even in the
polls or a one-point advantage or a
two-point advantage and I'm talking
about more specifically I'll break it
down Georgia New Hampshire Pennsylvania
Nevada uh and Arizona in particular
those races seem to be the toughest
right now I'd add Tiffany Smiley in
Washington State uh when you see races
that are that tight how should people
interpret that because now you're
talking about you know between all those
races I just mentioned you know maybe 30
40 50 000 votes will determine the
winner and all those races combined
well it could be we won uh with Reagan
we won control of the Senate when nobody
expected it and the total margin was
amazingly small but we kept winning
seats by ten thousand fifteen thousand
twenty thousand look there are two
things to remember here one is Robert
kahali of Trafalgar has said over and
over again with all of the vicious
hateful language from Biden and others
you suppress the Republican willingness
to talk to pollsters so uh kahali says
it's much harder to get an accurate read
on Republicans right now because they
frankly don't want to tell people what
they're going to do and the the the
hostility has been so great in the news
media so one the polls are almost
certainly under counting Republicans two
is I just did a newsletter that goes out
from English 360 today this is going to
be a hard weekend for the Democrats
people are going to go fill up their gas
tank they're going to go and fill out go
to the grocery store they're going to
watch the Evening News the the normal
weekend Carnage in Chicago the murders
in New York
um I think by the time it's over almost
nobody who's currently undecided is
going to decide to vote Democrat so you
can take if the Democrats below 51 or 52
percent I sus I personally believe
they're probably gone and I see so you
show me a 46-47 race the Democrats seems
to be ahead by one no that Democrats at
47 they're probably behind 53-47 because
I think all the final votes are going to
go against the Democrats you know I've
learned over the many years and being
the MC the night you became Speaker of
the House a a night I'll never forget
and was honored to be a part of uh
you've never been wrong you are almost
always right so I trust your your
confidence almost always almost always
but very consistently you give a very
objective analysis we'll be watching uh
speaker Gingrich thanks for being with
us hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere else